Schon in vier. Jahren sollen tief im weltall. Zwei sterne verschmelzen und uns eine waschechte. Nova bieten
ein blutroter fleck im sternbild schwan wird erwartet
So hell wie der polarstern sichtbar nicht nur mit riesigen teleskopen sondern mit dem bloßen auge davon geht zumindest
Ein us astronomenteam aus wie wahrscheinlich solch eine
Vorhergesagte sternenexplosion tatsächlich ist und alle weiteren weg zu diesem thema bekommt ihr jetzt herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Gestern lag ich noch bei mir auf dem hausdach hier in berlin
Und beobachtet die die sterne total beeindruckend war dass man trotz der lichtverschmutzung hier in der großstadt
Noch, einige sehen kann zum beispiel den jupiter. Und wenn man genau. Hinguckt sieht man
Auch dass er wirklich größer als die sterne ist. Und eine. Kleine fläche hat hammer
Kommen wir zum thema natürlich mal wieder über whatsapp vorgeschlagen vielen dank genauer gesagt geht es. Um, zwei sonnen die im
1842 lichtjahre entfernten stern system kec 98 32
27 kollidieren sollen das ergebnis eine sogenannte rote. Nova diese these hat. Ein
Amerikanisches forschungsteam auf der jahrestagung der american astronomical society im letzten jahr verkündet wenn
Sie recht behalten und wie diese sternexplosion tatsächlich mit bloßem auge beobachten
Können wäre es tatsächlich zum ersten mal in der geschichte der menschheit der fall dass dies mit ansage. Passiert die us astronomen
Und astronomen haben hinweise darauf gefunden dass der doppel stern im sternbild schwan
Kurz vor einer explosion steht konkret besteht aus zwei sternen die
Sich umkreisen schon jetzt sind sie sich so nah dass sich ihre, äußeren hüllen berühren dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Larry molnar die beiden sterne teilen eine einzige atmosphäre wie zwei erdnüsse in einer
Gemeinsamen schade forschungs 7 weltweit sind an der sache dran und messung nahmen bereits
Erste ergebnis offenbart elf stunden brauchen die beiden sterne für eine umkreisung doch die. Umlaufbahn des pärchens hat sich in den. Letzten
Jahren, verändert der lichtschwächere stern der beiden benötigt eine deutlich kürzere zeit, um an dem zweiten stern vorbeizuziehen
Und er nimmt an fahrt auf viele untersuchungen wurden durchgeführt
um
auszuschließen dass das verhalten des doppelsterns nicht auf einen dritten stern zurückzuführen ist ja und bislang
Sprechen alle hinweise dafür dass es sich. Um, zwei sterne halt die. Eben kurz vor ihrer verschmelzung stehen
Und nicht unter dem schwerkraft einfluss eines anderes. Anderen sterns stehen das alles erinnert an den doppelstern v13
Und 90 der 2008 explodierte nachdem sich seine beiden sterne immer näher gekommen waren fest steht dennoch das 2 sterne
Miteinander kollidieren das passiert sehr selten es gibt schätzungen nach denen von den
100 milliarden sterne in der milchstraße kaum einer eine kollision hinter sich hat sie im vorfeld aber sogar
noch vorher
Zu bestimmen das erinnert schon fast sechs richtigen im lotto bisher ist e10 98 32 27 übrigens nur mit
Starken teleskopen zu sehen falls es aber wirklich. Zu einer roten nova
Kommen sollte wird sie wohl. So hell strahlen wie der nordstadt bzw die sehr hellen sterne des großen wagens
Und das forschungsteam kann es selbst kaum fassen dazu mit war laut das wäre ein bedeutendes ereignis nicht nur für die wissenschaft sondern auch
Weil es die menschen auf der straße faszinieren kann wenn die vorhersage stimmt
Dann, wäre dies das erste mal in der geschichte dass eltern auf eine dunkle stelle am himmel zeigen können
Und sagen seht kinder dort versteckt sich. Ein stern der bald ganz hell
Aufleuchten wird hammer wir werden darüber berichten vielleicht sogar live wenn. Ihr kein video dazu und auch
Zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt die youtube aber box die funktioniert. Ja einfach gar nicht
Dann hättet mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst der kein video über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
Noch vor allen. Anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier
Draufklicken, und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks. Um
Social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür ihr klicken aber nicht
Immer die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken da geht es
um eine sensationelle, supernova, und
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran